the work alex trebek did on jeopardy is
the stuff of tv legend
but let's not forget he was a
philanthropist and most importantly
he raised three terrific kids yeah he
sure did and only our lauren zema spoke
with his oldest daughter nikki
about how they're honoring their
father's memory
[Music]
we saw him share the diagnosis with the
world i was diagnosed with stage four
pancreatic cancer
how did he share it with you with his
family what were you seeing on his face
oh
you're gonna get me at that moment i
thought wow
okay he's been stricken with this so he
can
he can he's gonna be the example you
know and um
he did really well for a really long
time so proud of him
nikki told me she has not watched
jeopardy since her father passed
and as for who could take over as host i
just know
that dad would have been supportive to
everyone and given everybody his best
wishes
and i do hope that they take their time
you know they're going to make great
choices
to honor her dad nikki is raising
awareness in the battle against
pancreatic cancer
launching a team for this year's virtual
purple stride walk
which her father attended there is hope
and if we keep working at it
we will beat cancer last week nikki her
sister emily and brother matthew helped
inaugurate a new homeless shelter
named for alex i just always remember
him you know being by my side so
a lot of memories thirty-one-year-old
matthew donated alex's suits from
jeopardy to the doe fund
so they can be worn on job interviews by
people looking to get back on their feet
i'll run into people still on the street
today and tell me
how greatly they were affected when
my dad had passed were there any pieces
whether it was a suit or tie or maybe
something else that you kept yourself
for sentimental reasons
i kept a tie that my mom had given my
dad
this is a big question but what do you
want his legacy to be
he's an extremely gracious man i can
only learn to be more gracious in my
life
on this planet from him
and so generous his donations his gifts
will change lives for generations he's
becoming even more beloved even after
his passing i agree with you to the man
he is
yeah absolutely